the raiders coming off a pretty tough
monday night loss to their division foe
of course the la chargers but as 8
sports now kevin martin reports no
matter the outcome on the field they're
still winning in the community
raiders defensive end max crosby has
proven he has a knack for hounding
opposing quarterbacks and speaking of
hounding well the sac specialist also
specializes in hounds specifically
rescued pit bulls max who has three
pitbulls of his own leo brooklyn and
dirk and homie a tech-based real estate
company partnered to support pits to
pets a local charity that rescues
pitbulls and other large breeds and then
rehabilitates them to find them forever
homes so i'm a proud pitbull owner i
know that pitts and other large dogs can
make great pets when well trained and
cared for that's why i'm proud to have
partnered with homie to support pits for
pets a local charity that rescues pit
bulls and other large breeds and then
rehabilitates them with the goal of
finding them forever homes for every
home that homie sells this october in
southern nevada homie will donate 250
dollars to pits for pets kevin martin 8
sports now
tough guy with a big heart well get
ready for the action every sunday
morning with our raiders pregame show it
starts at 8 a.m and don't forget 8 news
now is home of the most televised
raiders game so be sure to keep it
locked on channel 8. we'll